from timcast.com
leading michigan gop gubernatorial
candidate ryan kelly raided arrested in
connection with january 6th protest
timcast.com reports the candidate was
rated on june 9th on misdemeanor charges
related to the protest he is facing four
misdemeanor charges knowingly entering
or remaining in a restricted building
disorderly destructive conduct knowingly
engaging in any act of physical violence
against a person or property in a
restricted building or grounds and
willfully injuring or committing
depredation against property of the u.s
the charging documents do not accuse
kelly of ever entering the building he
is accused of gesturing for people to
move forward while on the capitol steps
they also say that i guess he he
assisted in someone pulling down
he's also accused of using his hands to
support another rioter who was pulling a
metal barricade so they have photos
that they argue is this guy now here's
what it's important
ryan kelly is currently polling at 19
he is up four points he is the gop front
runner for the primary to go up against
gretchen whitmer
so we have one of two scenarios
we either have the doj being weaponized
to shut down popular pro-trump
candidates or we have a
popular candidate who is an
insurrectionist now think about either
scenario if you're a democrat you're
looking to this guy and you're like this
guy was that january 6
and he's winning right what does that
say about the american people in that
perspective now i certainly don't
believe that narrative i think what
we're seeing is the weaponization of the
doj against political rivals yeah this
guy should have been there he shouldn't
have been gesturing people if that's
what he was doing sure the rioters
should be charged but to see an fbi raid
on a prominent politician over
misdemeanors it's clearly to me right
this is another question just really
quickly right before an election right
you know when they had the footage they
knew this was going on i mean how long
did it take them to to process
everything to and now they're doing it
sorry
it's been a year and a half yeah i
wouldn't say if if he is uh an
insurrectionist he's not a very good one
that's all he did yeah well and this is
the point right they have this entire
insurrectionist narrative and the idea
is that the sitting president of the
united states who was the
commander-in-chief and has control over
the entirety of the armed forces right
decided to overthrow the government have
a coup and he did this
by having a bunch of civilians without
any guns
enter a building they weren't supposed
to be in and and many of them didn't
even go in the building many of them
didn't go in the building and many of
them were waved in by police officers
and didn't do anything violent and it's
not even many of them it's a fraction of
a percent right that did i'm just
imagining you know these these hearings
the hearings are happening now i don't
care and they're going to be like this
was a plot
by a sitting president to overthrow this
country a city and i'm going to explain
to you how he did it yeah he vaguely
mentioned something about walking
towards the capitol yeah and then what
happened took a selfie towards the
capitol a bunch of people some some
people rioted maybe a few hundred and
then about half of them went in the
building
and then a bunch of people were let in
by the police and they walked around
taking selfies with those cops and then
left peacefully yeah exactly this is
this this is the sitting president
commander-in-chief in control of the
military literally has access to the
button that launches nukes and his plot
to overthrow the united states
government and become some kind of
dictator was to have civilians none of
whom are virtually none of whom brought
any guns there were no go towards the
capital vaguely gesture that they had in
that area this was a coup it was the
worst coup ever in the history of the
world well these hearings that we're
going to be hearing about on national
television the january six committee
hearings they're putting out all the
stops they want to make sure that this
is going to be a spectacle they brought
in the former president of abc news the
man that squashed the jeffrey epstein
story that suppressed it that spiked it
that made sure that this was the famous
story the amy robich robichav
project veritas story right
rohrbach where she specifically said we
had bill clinton we had all the evidence
we had this years ago and it was
squashed by abc news that man that was
in charge of that is going to be now
presenting the showcase spectacle that
is going to be presented to the american
public in just a few hours from now so
you can only expect how corrupted and
how bad and how just emotionally
manipulative it's going to be attempted
to sway the american public towards
seeing something that that again has
been highly manipulated from day one
i want to make another point here this
is something that actually came from
polling data and i've quoted this on the
show before but
more people who were polled from the
general public want to see an
investigation into the 2020 riots than
want to see an investigation into
january 6th so where's that isn't it a
threat to our democracy that we're
investigating an event which a minority
wants to see investigated rather than
something the majority wants to be
investigated i'm pretty sure more people
want hillary clinton investigated uh
yeah i think even a large portion of
democrats did or just released the list
of uh you know the clients for maxwell
that's right you know yeah that would be
enough and then elon musk just a few
days ago even asked how come the doj
hasn't leaked that information nope and
that's a very important question that i
think we should be asking because we are
seeing the doj weaponized in a very
strong way we just had
another trump administration member
arrested just a few days ago at the
airport uh
peter navarro
he's been on the show before and he was
in contact with the federal authorities
and he said you need anything you need
me to come in you need me to provide
evidence let's talk we'll work it out
they set him up at the airport and he
says he was treated like an allocated
terrorist which which is not surprising
in these days uh especially with just
how overbearing and just how insane
institutions like the fbi have been that
just a few weeks ago we found out set up
this whole gret and richmore kidnapping
plot which again was totally uh unfolded
as a jury ruled that the people there
were entrapped by the fbi the jury no no
the gretchen whitmore whitmer whitmer
which more i think is a little bit more
better potentially appropriate that
actually is better
i think
luke makes a very good point here uh so
the fbi raids his house over
misdemeanors we saw an instance uh when
we were talking i believe with nick
cersei about his film capital punishment
of these two old ladies who had the fbi
knock at their door because they walked
through the capitol after they were
welcomed in by police and then
we go to the epstein story the fbi
raided his island
and there has not been a single
indictment related to it you're telling
me they didn't find enough evidence to
indict a single people
the fbi had witnesses coming forward for
over 30 years and they decided to ignore
those witnesses in that very specific
case the fbi aided and abetted this
larger international trafficking and
extortion operation which uh which again
shows you just how badly corrupted
institutions could be inside of
washington dc leading to the suffering
of thousands of children in unspeakable
ways what we should want i believe as a
society is to know why our government is
so bad at actually investigating anybody
that's going to mess with little kids
how why are we so bad at that
that i mean historically over and over
again this is what our justice system is
actually really bad at and i think the
vast majority of americans want to
protect children absolutely if there's
any purpose of a justice system right
right
bad at or
yeah i think they're good at not
investigating right i think they have a
goal like the same thing went on for how
long over 30 plus years right that we
know of and then the first round came
forward the first victim came from the
first guy to do something like this and
get away with it under the government's
nose exactly so i i look at this story
and uh this was like a holy moment
when uh
when this guy got arrested because
any way you cut it right the it's i i
think luke put it well they're doing
this
only a few months before the midterm
this guy is the front runner they're
shutting down a front runner aside from
that this is a guy who's done multiple
rallies where he said you stop the
stealing all those rallies and things
like that
people agree with him and they vote for
him right you know i think what you see
with like youtube they they ban anybody
who agrees with trump or pushes that
narrative because they're doing
everything they can to suppress this
exactly this yeah
it's it's it's all part of the same
machine
yeah the interesting thing if you
actually go back and look at the the
descriptions that they that they used
all the things that he did that were
wrong
they actually described everything that
happened with the blm riots
and you know so we don't we don't use
the same level of justice we're not
measuring the same things for both of
these instances and like you said most
people really do want to know what
happened with these uh with these riots
and i think this is absolutely crazy i i
think that the this is what you're going
to see from the democrat party in the
midterms they're going to run on three
things you're going to run on abortion
they're going on a second amendment take
away our second amendment and they're
going to run on january 6 because what
else are they going to run on well yeah
they don't have a good economy but even
with those issues the particular stance
that they've taken on those are all
losing issues so gun control has been a
losing issue for the left for years and
years and years like this is not
something they've been successful with
and then even with their particular
position on abortion i've said a million
times on this show i'm pro-life
most pro-choice people are not as
extreme as the democratic party is with
their position so when they say
and everyone was arguing this oh if the
supreme court overturns roe they're
going to be handing the election of the
democrats absolutely not because what
the dems are going to do
which is what they have done is come out
with the most extremist
abortionist legislation that most
pro-choice people are going to say they
wouldn't be willing to accept right we
talked about it yesterday in california
they're talking about post-term abortion
it's a huge problem so but going back to
january 6 i believe that this is what
the le the radical left is using to
squash political dissent and that's
that's the real problem is if we're
using this i mean we have political
prisoners right now in the united states
yeah yeah that's that's both sides of
the aisle should this would be grave
concern to all of us
because then what's the what's what's
the next step what are we going to do as
a society if we now have political
prisoners let me let me let me go back
in time
20 2016 donald trump was saying lock her
up
because you'd be in jail you said to
hillary clinton sorry people started
chanting lock her up a lot of people on
the left were like this is dangerous
rhetoric i agree it is of course i think
hillary clinton has done a lot of
nefarious stuff and should be
investigated thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you